stell dir vor
seit jahren tüftelt du an einer
zeitmaschine mit der du in die
vergangenheit reisen kannst endlich ist
der große tag sie ist fertig als erstes
willst du deinen großvater treffen den
du nie kennengelernt ist
auf geht's 60 jahre zurück
doch deinen besuch kommt etwas
überraschend
was wenn mein großvater stirbt und ich
schulterlange tief durchatmen immer mit
der ruhe ist das überhaupt möglich
angenommen mein großvater stirbt jetzt
tatsächlich dann hätte das zur folge
dass ich nie geboren worden wäre und gar
nicht in die vergangenheit hätte reisen
können
aber ich bin ja hier also muss er leben
was aber wenn er doch noch stirbt dann
gibt es mich ja gar nicht mehr dass ich
überhaupt hier bin hängt davon ab dass
mein grossvater liegt
nein so kann die zeitreise nicht
funktionieren unmöglich also was ist
passiert
ich bin in der zeit zurückgereist
dadurch habe ich die vergangenheit
verändert also bin ich in einem anderen
einem zweiten universum gelandet in
einer parallelwelt der großvater den ich
in der vergangenheit getroffen habe ist
da nur so etwas wie ein zwilling meines
echten großvaters und dieser zwilling
kann sterben ohne dass mir etwas
passiert
er ist schließlich nicht mein echter
großvater oder ist das doch so ich bin
tatsächlich im selben universum in der
zeit zurückgereist zu meinem echten
großvater
dann aber kann er unmöglich sterben
denn ohne ihn gäbe es mich nicht und ich
wäre nicht da und schon gar nicht auf
dieser zeitreise
tja der schmerzt der kopf sind reisen in
die vergangenheit überhaupt denkbar